joining me here now from the New Orleans
Saints pleased to have on the Rich Eisen
show Demario Davis how are you Demario
I'm blessed man I'm blessed man I can't
complain appreciate you joining us right
here on the show what's going on in your
mind - Mario I'll just give you the
floor on that what's going on between
your temples you'd like people to know
about right now right well you know it's
it's real you know strange times I think
everybody's emotions all over the place
everybody's trying to make sense of
things and you know two things that I
tried to rely on is my faith first you
know that always brings back to balance
and then just my love for Humanity
second is my neighbors loving my
neighbor that always kind of brings me
back like into a central you know
mindset you know I think there's a
global outcry right now behalf of the
black community you know just you know
there's been hundreds of years of
oppression and finally just that I guess
the line has been drawn and everybody's
just kind of tired of it and saying you
know what we have to do something on
behalf of these people because people
group and you know as long ago do it's a
shame that we have to deal with this in
our lifetime but you know it's just
going on now and it is real and you know
I just think we should just deal with it
you know and we passed in the next issue
that we have in this country shouldn't
involve you know race especially around
black people well I know you've spoken
publicly since the team meeting last
week about what happened in that team
meeting a couple days after drew brees
said what he said which feels like a
year ago now certainly since what drew
has done and said and tweeted and
instagrams since then but what was that
meeting like what can you share with the
listeners and viewers of this show what
that that videoconference meeting was
like you know what goes on the team mean
you know I don't think anybody should
you know talk about something that was
private but you know when it pertains to
the drew as it pertained to millionaires
pertaining to captaining like we're
making our mistakes a mistake
we made in 2017 when we took the
conversation to something that it wasn't
shouldn't have never been about you know
I think the outcome global outcry this
you know happening around the world
right now is around no black people and
more specifically around police
mentality and making sure that you
change the way that we do policing black
communities especially and you know we
need to be spending more time talking
about that and how do we find you know
solutions to that you know all these
people speaking out and you know these
are the conversations that we should be
having first talking about you know ship
laden LLL ensure you know what somebody
stands on this what somebody stands on
that let's just talk about you know
issue at hand and find solution and let
you know let's not let the conversation
be dominated by anything except that
well I mean and I say to that
you know amen
you know because I was talking with the
journalist Robert Klem Co of the
Washington Post in the last hour Demario
about you know this is going to be the
conversation you know in the fall is our
players kneeling and what's the ly gonna
do about it if they should do anything
about it is the league fine with it
that's gonna be the conversation and how
does that not drown out the conversation
that's necessary to be had because the
kneeling has nothing to do with the
anthem or the flag it has to do with
what exactly you said so how do you I
guess solve that issue when clearly we
are expecting some sort of protests to
take place with players when football is
played this fall going on right now
there's a much more extreme protest
happening in the streets right now we
have me and the people who are
protesting and marching in the streets
not just in America needs the people of
all ethnic groups you know these and
these are people all around the world in
different countries taking their streets
and marching specifically on behalf
like black people and you know bringing
justice to the cosplay responsible for
the death of Joyce Lord cops responsible
to death through my daughter's Cosmo on
foot therefore Brianna Taylor and you
know that's what I think the
conversation should be around like why
why are we talking about a form of
protest that may or may not take place
in the fall when there there's a much
greater protest there more people in the
streets and there is an entire interfere
and so why are we talking about this
global outcry that is going on that
players are actually participating like
why are the players in the street let's
talk about that you know let's talk
about the formal protest that they're
taking now while I play speaking out now
you know while players being engaged in
our community and meeting with
legislators meeting with activists right
now let's just talk about that so let's
talk about that - Mario Davis then um
what what do you want people to do like
if you could you know just yeah I'll
give you my platform our platform here
at this show what do you want people to
do when they hear you and and hear your
fellow NFL players take to the streets
and what change what justice for these
families and understand that we can't
really bring just pretty something's
because you know we can't bring them
back you know that would be readjusted
but we can honor those families in first
convicting you know the cops that are
responsible for these murders you know
and I think that will go I will go a
long way towards being symbolic of
changes on the way and I'll be
convicting these could accosted are
responsible we can change the way that
we do policing in America you know after
we we in America know how to respond to
crisis after 9/11 we change the way that
we go through airports you never go
through airport and to be the same
changed up the entire process change the
way that you know the tears the TSA
workers check you so we can change the
way we certainly can change the way that
we do
policing in our country I think you know
there are a ton a ton of good police
officers we define a way to empower
those good police officers to to help
you know eradicate you know the police
department
Badcock I think we need to find ways to
empower prosecutors to be able to
prosecute the bad cops when they when
they do wrong things and there'll be a
greater sense of accountability there's
a bill on the floor right now about to
be passed or that we hope to get past
that that person into qualified immunity
you know pretty much that lets police
officers move untouched and you know so
things of that nature that helps us you
know change the way that we do policing
in our country I think that's first and
then we need to be again detect racism
is in the heart but we can attack the
racial injustice structures that exist
in our country and so if we you know all
the people who are moving and say we
want to help the black community this is
how I let's begin with justice and let's
put it into black people being brutally
murdered in the street and then you know
let's let's work to end all these racial
injustice structures that exist in our
country the mario davis here on the Rich
Eisen show and then again in your own I
guess football a house is is everything
would you say cool now with you and and
drew and Britain and is there can you at
least share that coming out of your
conversations well I think I think we're
in it for any growth to happen to have
to do there have to be bridges and so
that's that's two sides you know coming
together I think there has to be that
mean size that that that admit to
wrongdoing and say you know it's gonna
you got a cooler action that you that
your words and your desire for
reconciliation is there and on the other
side there has to be great you know and
then from there you have to move on and
focus on the bigger mission which is all
of us working together to for the end
goal and so I think you know our locker
room can very much be a model to the
rest of the country allow we heal from
from from our past you know and so
there's been because they're wrong it's
been done it again for specific people
group you know and there has to be
action first you know to say you know
want to reconcile and their actions
showing that there the desire for
reconciliation and then
that has to be a grace that allows that
reconciliation to happen and then what
that bridge has been formed and working
together we can work together towards to
a solution no no and live peaceful that
house together and in terms of action
again I know you know we try to not
stray into the political but there was a
tweet from drew brees to the President
of the United States essentially
explaining that his public stance about
the flag is something that he has heard
from from his teammates and about what
he said about never agreeing with
anybody who does that he has now after
the conversations with you are you as
not just you I imagine but your
teammates that we can no longer use the
flag to turn people away or distract
them from the real issues that face our
black communities and it was a tweet
directly to the president is that what
did you think of that Demario well I
would just say you know I would
encourage all of America and drew to
follow up on those those actions those
words you know drew made a statement
well he's pretty much saying he has
overlooked the black community and wants
to start working to help it I would
encourage everybody in America to follow
and if drew does that you know that's
leadership and then America has a model
to follow of what that should look like
and you know this problem that exists in
America is gonna take all of us to fix
it you know and that's what we that's
what we have peace and that's what I
meant by drew when I said it's
leadership for him to say what he was
going to do but leadership is most
importantly marked by action and I think
that he has opportunity to lead America
and what action should look like and in
assisting and helping alleviate the
burdens of the black community Demario
Davis here on the Rich Eisen show and
again I I'm part of me is like you know
I don't know if I should want to bring
it I mean
bring it out but because again we are
talking about issues that affect so many
people as you have mentioned it's not at
the grassroots of trying to root out
this awful scourge of racism but players
colleagues of yours in the NFL are
saying that one way for the NFL to help
matters Carlos Hyde in particular is to
say Colin Kaepernick should get a job
would you agree with that being a
necessary course of action for the NFL
Demario Davis well I would go as far as
to say that you know though this does
though this does take away from from the
ultimate from the ultimate conversation
you know I would go as far as to say as
it pertains to having a problem with
Colin Kaepernick taking a stance against
proof police brutality that he is
definitely owe the apology you know by
the NFL and everybody else who said that
that they were on the wrong side of it
you know I'm saying he shouldn't rip
that stand so I definitely think he's
owed an apology and so what that looks
like after that I don't know but I
definitely do believe he's owed an
apology but I think as far as the NFL
goes and anybody goes any bumpy pecans
control your industry and so if you want
to really help you know it can be marked
by action you know be the example you
know not not have the worries but but be
the example to the world of what that
looks like so before I let you go
let's call everybody's attention to WWF
t6 man of God calm you are creating a
man of God masks for people to wear in
in practicing social distancing because
yes we were in the middle of a pandemic
- and you're donating proceeds to the
families to the Floyd armory and tailor
families is that correct - Mario that is
correct that is correct and what else
are you doing you're visiting five
cities in five days right now you're
getting about it you're in the street
yeah trying to be trying to be you got
to get on the ground and hear the people
and
happens locally and so we were in
Atlanta yesterday and we're in DC today
and you know we're kind of gonna hit
gonna hit different cities and kind of
just kind of figure out as we go but
it's about being on being on the ground
with the people here in the problems
because you want to have solutions in
these communities you have to go to the
people and hear from them and once you
hear from the people you'll know what
what type of solutions need to be made
so people can follow you on Instagram D
56 Davis as well you were posting some
photographs of your stint in a Gertz
staying in Atlanta yesterday you're in
the nation's capital today and everyone
should tune in to see where you're going
next do you expect to be in a training
camp in July the mario do you expect
that this is all gonna be worked out
health-wise and and you're gonna have a
playing season do you think III don't
know I don't know I just I just I took
the people who have to make those
decisions yeah when it's a for everybody
that we all can collectively you know
get back get back moving in and do
whatever we needed you know whatever we
need to get done in that time I try to
focus on the moment try to focus from
the day that's in front of it I trust
the people who I can make that decision
of when we return back and when it's
safe for everybody you know that's when
you know that we have to get back going
okay and then one last thing about that
meeting last week is it's true that it's
been widely reported that Shaq zoomed-in
Shaq was part of the conversation he's
like nine feet tall tomorrow you can't
miss him I mean you know even though he
might have been in a little square on
your screen but you can't you're not
even gonna let that out of Fight Club
huh yeah on a little college you know
who on there okay you never know she has
Sean Payton knows a lot of people
Demario I appreciate you calling in I
appreciate you sharing I appreciate you
doing what you're doing and being about
it and people can go to 56 man of God
calm to help raise money and also
practice social distancing with the man
of God man of God masks and and I really
appreciate you know I'm a New Yorker I
appreciated your stand with the Jets too
sir I really enjoyed what that's when
you play it right back at you thank you
that's Damario Davis here on the rich
honest
show